notre invité politique ce matin c'est
sébastien chenu bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
député du nord porte parole du
rassemblement national et vous êtes
candidat aux régionales dans les hauts
de france à la tête de la liste du
rassemblement national merci d'être avec
nous on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par pascal jalabert bonjour
pascal du groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france
on va bien sûr parler des régionales et
de votre campagne sébastien chenu mais
d'abord le reste de l'actualité ces
milliers de manifestants qui ont défilé
ce week-end pour les libertés contre les
idées d'extrême droite c'était le têt le
thème de la manifestation à paris
jean luc mélenchon a été en farine et
est-ce que vous condamnez ce geste les
mois je condamne toutes les violences et
j'en ai d'ailleurs qu'il en soit de même
lorsque par exemple la tête de marine le
pen est portée au bout d'une pique là on
n'entend jamais personne en revanche
donc moi je condamne la violence quelle
qu'elle soit en politique
ces manifestations étaient ridicules et
très peu de participants parce que tout
simplement les gens qui les anime
d'abord sont obsédés par le
rassemblement national
alors qu'on préférait les sentir obsédé
en ce qui concerne la sécurité la lutte
contre l'immigration les grandes
problématiques de notre pays plutôt que
d'être obsédé par des des concurrents
politiques mais surtout il suffit de
demander aux gens aux habitants qui sont
dans des communes gérées par le
rassemblement national s'ils ont
l'impression d'être gérée par des gens
d'extrême droite c'est-à-dire par des
gens qui sont en rupture avec l'idéal
républicain où la démocratie va pas du
tout la réalité c'est que le to do
maires sont très bien réélu c'est que
tout ça se passe très bien et que ce
qu'on essaye de faire croire aux gens ne
marche plus ne prends plus c'est pour ça
qu'il y avait très peu de personnes en
réalité dans ces manifestations
ce mélenchon il devrait faire attention
la police 5000 selon les organisateurs
monsieur mélenchon devrait faire
attention dans ce qu'il fait parce que
lorsque lui il hurle sur des policiers
lorsque lui ils insultent des policiers
lorsqu'il a des propos complotistes
lorsqu'il est dans des manifestations
dans lesquelles on use on hurle allahou
akbar il sort gravement lui du pacte
républicain
alors je veux bien qu'on voit toujours
la main d'extrême droite derrière tous
derrière un cri comme montjoie saint
denis on voit avec d'ex à droite mais
derrière al hawa de barre dans les rues
de paris
il ya quelques temps ils étaient
nombreux là on n'a pas vu l'islamisme on
n'a pas vu de l'islam politique
et pourtant ils étaient bien là soutenu
par des hommes politiques de gauche et
d'extrême gauche donc un moment tout ça
confine au ridicule
les électeurs du rassemblement national
ils ont le droit tout autant que les
autres d'être respecté moi je respecte
tous les électeurs faut cette marche
c'est un manque de respect envers les
électeurs j'ai évidemment parce qu'on
essaie de les faire passer pour ce
qu'ils ne sont pas évidemment à partir
du moment où on essaye de on est dans le
jeu démocratique et où on accepte les
règles les uns et les autres
eh bien on se comporte de la même façon
les avis des électeurs bon je crois que
souvent il y as derrière ces attaques
toujours irraisonnée contre le
rassemblement national
l'incapacité à tous ces gens à assumer
la nullité de leur bilan en fait au
moins tant qu'on parle pas du bilan ton
qu'on parle pas des idées politiques et
quand on agit simplement des fantasmes
et bien on n'est pas sur le fond donc
tout ça les français ne sont pas dupes
et je pense que comme je le disais
effectivement nous avons droit au
respect à nos électeurs ont droit au
respect ou s'il échoue il n'y a pas de
bilan puisque inapte à gouverner
si on prend la retraite à 60 ans si on
prend le rapport avec l'europe y compris
sur des points diplomatique finalement
vous n'être pas si loin vos électeurs
des siens monsieur mélenchon il a un
bilan
qui est celui d'un opposant politique
est aujourd'hui au bout de cinq ans
d'opposition politique
le bilan de monsieur mélenchon c'est une
honte quand on a un leader politique qui
a les propos qu'il a allait propos je
disais complotistes ou qui est lié 1,19
politique qui est lié à l'islam
politique qui est lié à ces
revendications scandaleuse s'il un bilan
d'opposants qui devrait lui faire honte
et qui devrait l'inciter à se calmer
pour le reste pour les programmes les
français savent juger et très bien ils
le feront probablement très bien lors
des élections régionales qui sont ceux
qui ont un bilan à quel niveau
ce bilan plaît aux français je crains
que la république en marche là aussi ne
déchante quelque peu on va parler des
régionales mais on va continuer à
balayer le reste de l'actualité c'est le
général lecointe le général hawk one qui
a annoncé hier qu'il quittait ses
fonctions il ne veut pas d'un changement
de poste au moment de l'élection
présidentielle parce qu'il veut éviter
la politisation un soupçon politisation
de l'armée raisons ont écouté la
démission du général lecointe ne peut
pas ne pas nous faire penser à la
tribune signée par les généraux en
réalité on a le sentiment qu'il ya un
écho très direct les général lecointe
doit se sentir assez mal au milieu de
ses troupes qui ont dit tout haut ce que
de très nombreux militaires pensent tout
bas c'est à dire que la situation du
pays est tellement grave que s'il n'y a
pas par la démocratie par l'élection
un changement et un redressement du pays
alors ils seront c'est ce qu'ils
écrivaient dans la nécessité
d'intervenir il ne le souhaite pas y a
pas d'appel à la sédition non sens bien
que tous les soirs je sais pas ce que
dit le général le contre il a réagi hier
à cette tribune est dit que le risque de
coup d'état n'existe pas et que c'est un
fantasme mais bien sûr que le risque de
coup d'état n'existe pas et pas d'appel
à la sédition il y à un constat qui est
celui d'une société fracturée qui est
celui d'une société abîmé et ce sont les
militaires ceux qui donnent leur vie
pour défendre notre pays qu'il le dise
donc par conséquent on peut imaginer que
le g1 lecointre est plutôt mal à l'aise
aujourd'hui dans la fonction qui est la
sienne parce que il entend cette voix
qui montent dans l'armée et qui dit
qu'il est temps de se ressaisir comme
cette voix qui monte dans la justice
dans l'éducation nationale dans tout ce
qui se fait
les autorités du pays le régalien tout
ce qui tient notre société eh bien tous
les professionnels qui tiennent notre
société représente l'armée s'est pas je
pense qu'au contraire c'est très laid
c'est la face émergée de l'iceberg
c'est à dire que je pense au contraire
que de très nombreux militaires
considèrent que le pays dans un état
grave
il n'y a pas que les militaires qu'il
pense vous avez vu les tribunes de
magistrats vous avez vu les tribunes de
policiers vous entendez des enseignants
écrire à longueur de journée la
situation où des des soignants dans
laquelle ils sont oui l'état s'est
affaissé et pendant ces cinq ans il
s'est affaissé encore plus vite que les
années précédentes avec le gouvernement
des manuels macron la déconstruction de
l'état est allé encore plus vite pour
finir sur à ces militaires et à six
généraux retraités 1 mais qui peuvent
être appelés qui ont assumé leur rôle
dans cette tribune sur le délitement de
la france sécurité convoquée par le
ministère des armées vous trouvez que
cette procédure est normale mais moi je
ne remets pas en cause les procédures du
ministère de la défense mais ça doit
nous interpeller
si ces militaires ont considéré qu'il
devait s'affranchir de l'endroit de
réserve c'est qu'il considère que la
situation est donc avoir des sanctions
c'est qu'il considère que la situation
est suffisamment grave pour le faire
c'est ça qui doit nous faire réfléchir
est normal qu'ils soient sanctionnés
bien sûr bien sûr on sait dans quoi on
s'engage
lorsqu'on entre dans l'armée et je pense
que j'ai commencé à des procédures et
bien elles iront au bout c'est pas ça
qui me choque les militaires ne savent
même s ils ont décidé de s'en affranchir
c'est qu'il considère qu effectivement
mais si tu es sur notre pays est bien
dramatique
oui pour rester avec nos armes et le
président de la république veut réduire
la présence militaire au sel l'opération
barkan qu'en pensez vous
on ne peut pas parler de ceci sans avoir
une pensée pour les militaires ils ont
été près de 50 je crois qu'ils ont été
tuées pendant ces opérations durant ces
années et un retrait rapide qui
n'auraient pas été réfléchie me
semblerait ne pas et dans le bon sens et
un retrait doit se faire et doit être
progressif évidemment il ne doit pas
rimer avec un il ne doit pas rimer en
tous les cas avec la volonté de cesser
de lutter contre l'islamisme dans ces
pays là nous devons demeurer des
partenaires de la lutte contre
l'islamisme dans ces pays là et pour le
reste voilà je crois que cette
un site a d'abord pensé à ces militaires
mais à se dire aussi que la france a été
bien seul
durant toutes ces années dans cette
opération barkan
nous avons été bien seul et l'union
européenne nous a démontré là aussi son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix ça
veut dire qu emmanuel macron a raison
dans sa stratégie
moi je n'en fais plus je me fie le
problème c'est qu'elle regagne ma
chronique sentiment de ne pas lire de
stratégie derrière on a l'impression
qu'il dit on arrête barkan mais qui a
pas de stratégie derrière j'attends de
savoir ce que le président nous propose
comme stratégie et vous l'attendez au
parlement vous souhaite un débat
parlementaire sur bien sûr ça semble
nécessaire on va dire un mot du
couvre-feu
puisqu'on a vu encore 1 ce week-end ces
images notamment à paris de non respect
des gestes barrières de non respect du
couvre-feu est ce que comme valérie
pécresse vous dites il faut mettre fin
dès maintenant couvre-feu à 23 heures
vous savez nous nous avons demandé
depuis bien longtemps que chacun puisse
retourner travailler
qu'il y ait des zones dans lesquelles
quand l'épidémie ne se répande ait pas
de façon très importante et lyon puisse
donner de la liberté aux français je
pense qu'il est temps effectivement
donné cette liberté aux français à
partir du moment où on continue et on
donne la possibilité de se vacciner là
aussi nous avons demandé il ya déjà très
longtemps qu'on vaccine très largement
les jeunes en particulier qu'on ouvre
les vaccinations et qu'on arrête de
faire par catégorie d'âge d'ailleurs oui
mais d'ailleurs il ya eu un
ralentissement oui juste cintrax ils le
font très largement ce qui permettrait
effectivement d'en finir mais j'ai sur
le off c'est tout moi je pense qu' il
faut une mesure qui n'a pas de
pertinence comme celle ci c'est l'état
sortie d'une vaccination ouverte est
possible pour tout le monde
alors évidemment mais me sens bien sûr
sur un autre sujet qui vous tient à
coeur l'immigration le président de la
république veut durcir les sanctions
administratives notamment les expulsions
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière
ça devrait vous convenir un pro pour des
faits graves at il précisé pour des
faits graves de choses et à la forme et
le fond sur la forme
enfin on se moque on se moque des
français en fendant pleine période
électorale
on est à dix mois de l'élection
présidentielle et on a besoin d'un
public et mes intérêts nous allons
expulser les situations les étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui ont commis des
faits graves sur ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
commis pour eux pas de soucis cantons
continuent à braver la loi et nous
allons à dix mois des élections
présidentielles devenir un peu fermé
c'est à dire monter le son bon ils ces
gens là se moque évidemment des français
il ya 13 % des demandes d'asile déboutés
du droit d'asile qui repartent chez eux
c'est à dire qu'il y en a 80 7% qui
n'ont pas le droit de se maintenir en
france et qui s'y maintiennent on a vu
dans les déboutés du droit d'asile
parfois il y avait des terroristes
parfois et souvent il y avait aussi des
gens qui se comportait mal et bien moi
je pense qu'il ne faut pas attendre
qu'il y ait un fait grave pour faire
repartir ces gens de là où ils
deviennent toute personne qui est entré
et qui s'est maintenue en situation
irrégulière dans notre pays doit être
reconduite à la frontière
on a le sentiment que ces gens-là fonde
font des analyses qui finissent par
ressembler à ce que nous proposons mais
en réalité ils n'osent pas aller au bout
des soleils cet apprenti boulanger de
bohain sont ses vrais ils n'étaient pas
en situation rien tout de suite mais en
tout cas son patron s'est mis en grève
de la faim parce qu'il a régularisé ce
garçon voulait travailler tous les
matins à 4h
il allait aux cours du soir pour
apprendre le français monsieur moi je
veux bien qu'on prenne l'exemple idéal
exceptionnel mais faites un tour dans
les prisons de france et vous allez en
voir d'autres des exemples qui sont un
peu moins exceptionnel est
malheureusement un peu moins idyllique
donc je veux bien le boulanger quand on
se maintient sur le territoire français
sans droit ni titre
on repart de là d'où on vient c'est
probablement ce qui nous différencie de
ces gens là qui font semblant d'être
ferme qui des fonds qui ont l'illusion
qui donne l'illusion aux français d'une
fermeté parce que c'est les élections
mais qui en réalité des élections sera
passée reviendront à leur très mauvais
penchants alors très mauvaise habitude
par absence totale de courage politique
quand on se maintient quand on brave la
loi pour tous se maintient en france
sans droit ni titre
on rentre de là
comment on fait ce que c'est pas et
c'est pas illusoire aussi de faire
croire aux français que c'est aussi
facile que ça et madame on le fait
d'abord en maîtrisant notre immigration
avec un moratoire sur l'immigration dans
notre pays mais aussi la gestion de nos
frontières
la gestion des migrations doit être une
politique nationale c'est exactement ça
tombe bien ce que propose marine le pen
pour les prochaines élections nous
devons avoir la capacité
ça me semble est d'une banalité sans nom
de pouvoir gérer qui entre qui sort qui
se maintient pour combien de temps sur
notre territoire
c'est une politique nationale et je suis
presque prêt à prendre les paris que
nous ils finiront que nous y arriverons
pas ce que vous avez vu que pendant la
corrida avec un an de retard
eh bien on a fini par gérer nos
frontières parce que c'était urgent et
nécessaire
et bien parce que la situation devient
urgente et nécessaire on finira avec
marine le pen évidemment la tête du pays
c'est aussi le discours que tient à
l'armada et emmanuel macron ce discours
en disant que pendant la présidence
française de l'union européenne ils vont
porter ce dossier mais pas vraiment de
plus plus grand contrôle de
l'immigration ils ne tiennent pas le
discours selon laquelle l'immigration
est une priorité est une prérogative
nationale
ils s'en remettent toujours à l'union
européenne éternel passoire donc non il
ya quelque chose qui m'a souvent s'il
n'allait pas être obligé de faire avec
et d'ailleurs l'arrivée de marine le pen
suffira probablement envoyer ce signal
mais je suis sûr que ce ne sera pas le
seul c'est ce que je pense que l'union
européenne mais ça valait la peine ces
fermetures des frontières
non mais c'est gestion des frontières
gestion de l'immigration niveau national
mais surtout je suis persuadé que
l'union européenne parce qu'elle s'est
déjà amendé sur un certain nombre de
points et c'est déjà amendé sur un
certain nombre de critères dont pas sur
l'immigration par exemple mais sur des
critères de finances publiques et bien
l'union européenne finira par accepter
de rendre de la souveraineté aux pays
qui n'en peuvent plus on a parlé des
régionales régionales dans les hauts de
france avant de parler des régionales un
mot sur cet échange plutôt vif ce week
end entre eric dupond moretti et et
votre lampe vos candidats au
départemental damien rieu il a qualifié
le ministre de pitbull à rolex de macron
est-ce que c'est du niveau d'une
campagne électorale sébastien chesnais
est ce que c'est du niveau d'une
campagne électorale qu un garde des
sceaux vie
de façon complètement débraillé insulté
provoquer des gens qui sont assis en
train de boire un café à péronne dans la
somme
est ce qu'en fait tout ça ne dit pas qui
rit dupond-moretti non seulement à
incarner effectivement c'est ce laxisme
mais n'a aucun projet pour la région
dans laquelle ils s'engagent aucun
projet on n'a jamais entendu eric
dupond-moretti faire une seule
proposition pour notre région qui en a
bien besoin
est-ce que garde des sceaux qui se
comporte finalement comme un agresseur
en venant agressé à une terrasse de café
des habitants du coin
oui il est venu il est venu agressé
verbalement s'amuser probablement parce
que eric dupond-moretti joue en réalité
eric dupont et il n'y a pas de sérieux
dans tout ça y'a pas que sérieux dans sa
démarche de candidats aux régionales ya
tellement pas de sérieux qui ne vient
que le week-end de se balader s creed du
monde pour mauricette à sa place dans
tout ça moi je crains que ce garde des
sceaux né à vienne qu'il serait plaint
sa place à une du progrès parce qu'il
n'a pas de projet pour la région parce
qu'il est un candidat de week end alors
qu eric dupond-moretti choisissent où il
est garde des sceaux à temps plein et vu
l'état de la justice on aurait bien
besoin de quelqu'un qui se penche sur
ces dossiers à temps plein ou et les
candidats aux régionales et il nous
parle de quelques propositions mais il
arrête de venir faire un numéro le week
end enfin et ce coup très sérieux
devenir une fois dans le pas de calais
le dimanche monté sur un terril insulter
les électeurs du rassemblement national
c'est ce qu'il a fait d'ailleurs en s'en
prenant à damien rieu sur la terrasse du
qatari fait la distinction mais entre
entre le rassemblement national entre
les élus et entre les électeurs duration
la rationalité que les électeurs du
rassemblement national il veut aller les
chercher
il veut leur expliquer
le projet il dit on peut pas avoir par
exemple sur la justice puisque c'est son
domaine on peut pas avoir un discours
café du commerce comme la le
rassemblement national je crois qu eric
dupond-moretti si c'est son objectif
s'il prend assez mal je suis prêt à
prendre les parts les paris qu'ils ne
reporte lundi de la semaine prochaine
dans son ministère un peu penaud
c'est à dire avec le résultat de ce
qu'il aura fait insulter des millions de
gens pendant des semaines des mois
s'être moqué des habitants des hauts de
france en n'ayant jamais eu une once
d'une proposition le début du
commencement d'une proposition
eh bien vous verrez la réponse des
électeurs la semaine prochaine on peut
prendre les paris aujourd'hui très
justement on va parler des électeurs
alors pas de la réponse des électeurs on
nie pas dans la boule de cristal mais en
tout cas des sondages pour le moment les
sondages qui vous donnent légèrement
derrière xavier bertrand au coude à
coude 1 au premier tour 34 % pour lui
32% pour vous en 2015 marine le pen qui
était la candidate du rassemblement
national du front national époque elle
faisait 40 % xavier bertrand il était à
25% est ce que quand même il n'a pas
réussi à affaiblir le rassemblement
national dans la région
oui vous savez on verra ça au moment des
résultats nous sommes dans ce qu'on
appelle la marge d'erreur je rappelle
que la dernière fois les sondages
donnaient marine le pen à 35% qu'elle a
terminé à 41
quand vous voyez quand même une petite
différence moi ce que je crois c'est que
dans cette région au 1er tour vous je
pense oui je pense que notre région elle
a été depuis toujours finalement géré
par les mêmes très longtemps gérée par
la gauche
la même une époque était le nord pas de
calais géré par les verts elle est
aujourd'hui gérée par les républicains
associé à la république en marche
je rappelle que gérald darmanin était
vice-président de xavier bertrand ces
gens là sont les mêmes sont d'accord sur
tout d'ailleurs c'est pas un problème
qu'ils soient d'accord sur tout encore
faut-il l'assumer ce que ne fait pas
bien xavier bertrand mais cette région
elle a subi les échecs de ses politiques
depuis 30 ans le temps l'alternance il
est venu l'alternance d'abord dans une
démocratie
elle est salutaire elle est nécessaire
c'est une respiration
ici elle est attendue elle est espéré
l'alternance ça permet d'ouvrir des
nouveaux dossiers le dossier de la
sécurité il n'a pas été ouvert par
exemple bertrand ça permet de mettre fin
j'y viens non il n'a rien fait justement
région il s'agit bien mais ça permet
aussi de mettre fin à de mauvaises
habitudes je le dis parce que vous avez
là un président de région qui soutient
encore son vice président maire de
roubaix qui ne veut pas couper de
subventions à des structures liées à
l'islam politique alors même que l'état
demande que tout cela cesse et bien
lancée et bertrand continue à soutenir
le maire de roubaix qui continue à
vouloir arrosé un certain nombre
d'associations à ayherre pour être très
précis comme ça chacun pourra se faire
son idée qui ont des liens avec l'islam
radical
donc il y a des ambiguïtés et des
incompétences des insuffisances aussi
sur la sécurité il ya un domaine de
compétence que nous connaissons qui est
celui des transports dans la région
mais on peut aller au delà dans chaque
politique qui est donc là vous
reconnaissez qu'il a fait des choses
qu'il a mis des moyens humains en
matière de 364 halte égard devait être
sécurisée dans notre région trente longs
étaient donc 10 % de ce qu'il de ce qui
était nécessaire
donc ya pas eu des forfaits là dessus
les agents de sécurité publique nous
demandons que dans les transports les
agents auront puissent embaucher 250
agents de sécurité publique y en a 2 115
il en a financé 35 foyers la faiblesse
en fait il n'a pas pris ce dossier à
bras le corps parce qu'il a considéré
que ce n'était pas sa responsabilité
moi je considère que c'est mon boulot où
ils viennent d'une région quand même la
première préoccupation reste l'emploi
rend pas citer les chiffres ici mais ils
sont indépendants plus d'ailleurs que
ces eaux douces et à la monnaie
nationale
vous allez bertrand mis en place des
réseaux à y a plus ou moins craint pour
l'emploi régional qu'est ce que vous
proposez
alors vous vous dites est la première
préoccupation c'est l'emploi d'ailleurs
je pense que emploi et sécurité ça
marche ensemble qu'on n'ait pas de
sécurité vous ne pouvez pas mener un
projet professionnel implanter des
entreprises
il ya eu vingt mille emplois industriels
détruits dans notre région le chômage
baisse moins fort dans la région qu'ils
ne baissent au niveau national c'est à
dire que les politiques mises en place
par xavier bertrand
c'est pas moi qui me lève il est placé
aussi quand il est arrivé moyenne
nationale mais la moyenne positive qui
s'appelle proches emploi il est toujours
plus forte moyenne nationale madame ça
dispositif la cour des comptes et ça
coûte cher ça marche pas ça crée pas
d'emplois donc ça veut dire que les
politiques il a mis en place n'ont pas
eu d'effet ni amplificateur ni
correctifs et que donc on a perdu du
temps le problème c'est qu'ils aient
bertrand a fait perdre du temps avec
toute une série de gadgets fort
médiatisé mais bien entendu fort inutile
il a fait perdre du temps notre région
alors d'un côté il n'a pas protégé
il a pas protéger la sécurité de ses
habitants et de l'autre côté il n'a pas
protégé son emploi et son industrie on
peut pas dire que le bilan ce soit très
glorieux nous sommes malheureusement
nous sommes malheureusement pas il faut
assumer sa part de responsabilité
nous sommes malheureusement classé parmi
les régions les plus mal gérées
je rappelle que l'ifrap et le journal
capital nous ont classé 12e sur 13 comme
les régions les plus les moins bien
gérés nous sommes dans perdu joue les 10
des emplois industriels
il n'y a pas d'investissement suffisant
-21% bertrand il m'avait juré sondages
c'est bien que quelques biens les
électeurs des hauts de france lyon parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y à la jambe gauche
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya des gens de
gauche qui s'était fait hara kiri qui
ont choisi de voter a dit bertrand au
premier tour en se disant de toute façon
on va nous y oblige et au second donc on
le fait dès le premier tour mais ça
cette illusion cette espèce darna qu'en
réalité elle ne tient pas longtemps et
c'était le but de cette campagne
électorale que d'expliquer l'oci et je
crois que les habitants le comprennent
que là où il n'y a pas de résultats là
où ça fait très longtemps que les mêmes
gère le même système c'est un système
gère notre région
eh bien il est temps de changer les
choses et la wii u de l'alternance en
général elle s'est bien passée et elle a
donné ses résultats
c'est ce que je propose aux habitants
vous craignez que la gauche ne se retire
pas cette fois ci et que du coup en
triangulaire voir en quadrangulaire si
l'horaire la république en marche se
maintient vous n'arrivez pas à gagner
cette région
non mais tout est possible ils peuvent
se maintenir ils peuvent se fusionner
ils peuvent se retirer enfin tout est
possible avec eux puisque leur seul but
c'est pas de sauver la région
leur seul but c'est de sauver leur place
et bertrand nous dit qu'il est candidat
et que dès qu'il est élu il part en
campagne présidentielle sans rien dire
d'ailleurs qui gérera la région ce câble
d'une désinvolture manifeste vides
attendait nommé 15 mai et compter
l'ancien en 2010 et xavier bertrand lui
en avait fait le reproche est ce que le
cynisme en politique c'est pas de faire
ce qu'on reproche à ses adversaires
c'est bertrand a reproché sa à marine le
pen pour finalement faire la même chose
est-ce que c'est pas le comble du
cynisme politique si je crois les
habitants ont droit à être respectés
on n'est pas le paillasson monsieur
bertrand on commence à entendre le
discours silence un national gagne un
territoire une région ça à faire peur
aux investisseurs et vous avez même des
investisseurs qui tiennent ce discours
des industries légères l'entreprise
comment vous réagissez enfin écoutez
c'est la même chanson chaque élection à
chaque élection il suffit de demander au
maire de perpignan de villers cotterêts
d'hénin-beaumont de bruay la buissière
ils ont tous eu le discours oulala si la
ville passe au rassemblement national
n'y aura plus d'investisseurs les
outrances du ministre de l'intérieur il
ferait mieux de s'occuper de son bilan
il ferait mieux de sécuriser les
français des protégés plutôt que de
commenter le vote des électeurs voient
ce que je crois c'est que tout ça c'est
l'éternel pippo
si le rassemblement national arrive en
responsabilité lova arrêté de couler
vous allez entrer en enfer etc
manque de pot à j'invoque leur assemblée
nationale est arrivé aux responsabilités
lui ou ses amis d'ailleurs je pense à la
ville de béziers
et bien tout a été non seulement la
sécurité a été renforcée
- 23 % de faits de délinquance à hénin
beaumont
je le rappelle à béziers je crois qu'on
est dans des proportions semblables et
les électeurs ont très bien conduit leur
mère donc faut arrêter avec ce pipeau ne
le croit que ceux qui veulent nuire au
rassemblement national juste un mot sur
une autre région la région bourgogne
franche comté c'est julien en doute
votre candidat là bas qui est contesté y
compris dans votre camp c'est une erreur
de casting vient d'autre non je crois
qu'il ya un acharnement sur julien houle
qui n'est pas juste vous savez on
moi je regarde ce que font les candidats
julien houle était président de groupe
connaît bien sa région il y est
entièrement dévoué et probablement il va
gagner et c'est probablement ce qui
suscite cet acharnement injustifié
contrôler quand même notamment sur les
agriculteurs n'ont ils sont contestés
madame ils sont bien sûr mais vous ne
pouvez pas affirmer quelque chose qui
est contesté par ses côtés c'est
simplement le journaliste de liberté
c'est un montage vous l'avez écouté
oui oui elle aussi un montage
visiblement il ya des morceaux entiers
de la conversation on va pas rentrer en
détail mais qui ne sont pas repris donc
oui il le conteste c'est un constat pas
complètement lui ont dit qu'il n'a pas
voulu dire ça il conteste avoir prononcé
ces mots
ils complètent ce qui en a été dit
madame moi je conteste par exemple que
je j'aimerais en tous les cas que le
député de la france insoumise candidat
aux régionales monsieur bernalicis qui
est accusé par son propre attaché
parlementaire sur les réseaux sociaux de
consommer de la cocaïne au bureau et de
harcèlement puisse s'expliquer également
vous en avez entendu parler
non vous n'en avez pas entendu par nos
noms plusieurs candidats lui assure
désinvesti du ressort national et il a
creusé il ya eu les ardennes la gironde
vous avez un problème dont nous avons
nous a cité trois personnes sur combien
de candidats 3600 peu importe et bien
moi je vous dis monsieur que ce qui
compte dans ces cas là c'est la réponse
qui est donné quand madame pécresse un
de ses candidats qui est accusé par son
propre fils de viol je n'en fais pas
porter la responsabilité notre pécresse
je pense que l de savez probablement
passage sinon elle n'aurait pas retenu
son candidat est bien l'une lorsque nous
avons des brebis galeuses et donc je
viens de vous démontrer qu'elles
pouvaient de la france à souligner ou
des républicains être présente partout
nous les désinvesti sont immédiatement
parce que nous avons trois mille six
cents candidats qu'il est possible
qu'ils aient des gens qui soient mal
comporté dans ces trois mille six cents
candidats mais nous le faisons
automatiquement mais ne nous faites pas
porter cette responsabilité que vous ne
faites pas porter à nos adversaires
politiques
quand bien même il héberge sur leur
liste parfois des gens peu
recommandables
merci beaucoup merci sébastien d'avoir
été notre invité pour des raisons
d'équité on va regarder ensemble la
liste des candidats dans ces régionales
en ile-de-france vous êtes 7 dans les
autres ans par dont vous êtes 7 ha à
briguer le poste de président de région
et je rappelle pour tous nos
téléspectateurs que le premier tour a
lieu dimanche prochain merci sébastien
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité
[Musique]